hello little peanuts and porcupines
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 55 I love
superheroes and I love good movies put
those two things together and I go king
bananas one of my favorite superhero
movies is of course Sam Raimi's original
spider-man not only because it's
brilliant storytelling and it is but
because that movie really conveys the
grace the almost billeted movement of
our hero through the New York City Scott
what gives spider-man his agility is a
combination of heightened reflexes and a
precognitive spider sense add to that
super strength and some handy webs and
you have the best time this side of
Superman indeed I've spent countless
hours walking through cities staring
wistfully up at buildings as the other
me the Spider Man may swings here and
there and deep parabolic arcs twisting
into triple flips landing I don't know
on the pole of some american flag atop
the Empire State Building yeah okay I
lost myself there a little bit though
I've been known to loiter around the
spider exhibit at the Natural History
Museum it's a real human tragedy that we
don't get to have superpowers I mean the
best we can do is free running and by we
I of course mean other people and yet
there are times when walking through the
densely populated spaces of Manhattan
that I've marveled at my ability to move
through a crowd and not crash into every
other person sometimes I can actually
feel myself perceiving the speed and
criss-crossing directionality of all the
people in front me and when I get to the
other side I feel like a regular Han
Solo what is that why aren't we a mess
in airports or on street corners how are
we all
avoiding one of them when we look out
onto a moving crowd but we're actually
seeing beyond busy people talking on
their cell phones is subtle increases
and decreases in the intensity of light
reflecting off objects when light
intensity increases an object is moving
towards you usually when it decreases
it's moving farther away but the retina
is also sensing directionality neurons
fire and encode as they sense edges
moving over backgrounds in time and we
have separate groups of neurons
dedicated to perceiving things moving
left or right or clockwise or
counterclockwise to perceive your own
sense of directionality in action fix
your eyes on the center of this
animation what I'm about to show you is
what's called the waterfall illusion or
motion after effect stare at a waterfall
for long enough and the neuron group
coding its downward motion will for lack
of a better term get bored and adapt to
make that the norm turn your head away
to say a stationary rock and the rock
will seem to move upward in the opposite
direction of the Falls that's because
the stationary thing relative to the
adaptive normal is actually up or
instead of circles moving inward this
pattern may look like it's moving
outward add to this our eyes on average
separated by six centimeters are
remarkably accurate at triangulating an
object as long as it's within 100 meters
if it's beyond 100 meters we have to
rely on other tricks like perspective or
motion parallax taking all this
information the brain can calculate the
velocity of a variety of moving things
at once the retina which we should never
forget is the only visible part of the
brain carries information via the optic
nerve through the lateral geniculate
nucleus and into the visual cortex in
the occipital lobe of the brain from
here the data splinters down two paths
the to stream hypothesis made famous by
David Milner and Melvin Goodell in the
early 90s holds that some information
goes down the ventral stream to the
temporal lobe for object identification
and recognition so that we can figure
out what it is that we're looking at the
rest goes down the dorsal stream to the
parietal lobe where we process the
objects spatial location relative to the
viewer in other words there's two
streams one for what and one for where
what was merely color edge and
brightness in the occipital lobe is a
mapped spatial awareness by the time it
reaches the Paria now our knowledge of
how we process movement is only as good
as our working knowledge of the brain a
grasp which is to say the least
incomplete better and finer technologies
will give way to a better and finer
understanding of the brain but really
understanding the brain is only a
function of our desire to understand it
or to treat certain kinds of brain
damage what's incredible is that when
functioning normally we don't have to
think about each and every complicated
step from perception to cognition to
action we can like certain heroic wall
crawlers navigate our environment with
natural grace in a kind of poetic dance
with the fast and chaotic movement of
everything else oh my god oh my god that
was spider Santa I knew it
whatever life holds in store for me I
will never forget these words with great
power comes great responsibility
this is my gift my curse Who am I I am
spider-man